Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Style transfer is an amazing area in machine
learning and AI research, where we take two
images.
Image number one is an input photograph, and
image number two, is the desired style.
And the output of this process is the content
of image number one with the style of image
number two.
This first paper opened up an incredible new
area of research.
As a result, a ton of different variants have
emerged in the last two years.
Feedforward style transfer for close to real-time
results, temporally coherent style transfer
for videos, and much, much more.
And this one not only outperforms previously
existing techniques, but also broadens the
horizon of possible style transfer applications.
And obviously, a human would be best at doing
this because a human has an understanding
of the objects seen in these images.
And now, hold on to your papers, because the
main objective of this is method to create
semantically meaningful results for style
transfer.
It is meant to do well with input image pairs
that may look completely different visually,
but have some semantic components that are
similar.
For instance, a photograph of a human face
and a drawing of a virtual character is excellent
example of that.
In this case, this learning algorithm recognizes
that they both have noses and uses this valuable
information in the style transfer process.
As a result, it has three super cool applications.
First, the regular photo to style transfer
that we all know and love.
Second, it is also capable of swapping the
style of two input images.
Third, and hold on to your papers because
this is going to be even more insane.
Style or sketch to photo.
And we have a plus one here as well, so, fourth,
it also supports color transfer between photographs,
which will allow creating amazing time-lapse
videos.
I always try to lure you Fellow Scholars into
looking at these papers, so make sure to have
a look at the paper for some more results
on this.
And you can see here that this method was
compared to several other techniques, for
instance, you can see the cycle consistency
paper and PatchMatch.
And this is one of those moments when I get
super happy, because more than a 170 episodes
into the series, we can not only appreciate
the quality of these these new results, but
we also had previous episodes about both of
these algorithms.
As always, the links are available in the
video description, make sure to have a look,
it's going to be a lot of fun.
The source code of this project is also available.
We also have a ton of episodes on computer
graphics in the series, make sure to have
a look at those as well.
Every now and then I get e-mails from viewers
who say that they came for the AI videos,
and just in case, watched a recent episode
on computer graphics and were completely hooked.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!